تماما يعني لم يطلب النظام او لم يصرح
النظام انه حتى بحاجه الى اي اغاثه او انه
بحاجه الى اي مساعده والنظام عليه ان يبدي
استعداده لاستقبال المساعدات وحمايه فرق
الاغاثه في حاله قررت احدى الدول ارسال
فرق وقررت المنظمات لكن لم يفعل ذلك حتى
ان النظام يقوم باستقبال المساعدات في
مطار دمشق الدولي علما ان المنطقه
المنكوبه الاكثر في سوريا هي حلب التي
تبعد 400 كيلو متر والنظام يدعي ان لديه
عجز في قطاع النفس وقطاع الطاقه وبالتالي
نقل
المواد الغذائيه الى حالات سيكون مربط
بالنسبه للنظام خاصه الاجواء الان لماذا
لا يتم ارسال هذه المساعدات الى مطار حلب
لا يريد النظام ذلك طبعا حلب موجود في
النظام وروسيا وايران هناك يستطيع النظام
على اقل تقدير ان يقول ان مطار حلب الان
هو استثنائيا يستقبل كل شحنات وكل شرح
تعليقاتها اذا كان فعلا صادق تريد ارسال
ذلك هناك طائرات فعلا هبطت في مطار دمشق
الدولي وافرغت شحنات من الاغذيه والادويه
خاصه وصلت قبل قليل وصلنا ان هناك طائرات
رقم ساده تقريبا ثالث طائره تصل من العراق
وصلت من ايران معنا الدول العربيه قدمت
لكن لغايه الان اؤكد لكم احياء حلب ومدينه
حلب لم تعرض شيء يسمى اغاثه حتى المبادرات
الفرديه لا يوجد من يتعاون معهم هناك احد
الاشخاص قال انه لديه سيارات اسعاف فقط هو
يحتاج وقود ولا يريد هذا الوقود مجانا
يريده بثمن فقط على الحكومه او على احد
المتنفذين ان يوفر لهم